in the last several videos we assume
that the velocity of the source of the
object that's emitting the wave we've
assumed that that's less than the
velocity of the wave and we saw what
happens with the Doppler effect and all
of that but what I want to do in this
video is not make this assumption in
particular let's see what happens at
least at first to our formulas and then
get a conceptual understanding let's see
what happens when the velocity of the
source is equal to the velocity of the
wave so the first thing we might try to
do is just apply this assumption this
new assumption into the formulas that we
had in the last video and those formulas
were here these are the observed period
and frequency for an observer that's
kind of in the direction of the object
and if we make this assumption that the
velocity of the sound and the velocity
of the source we're not necessarily
dealing with sound waves although that
might be an easy visualization for you
that's tends to be how I visualize it
but if what happens to these formulas
when the velocity of the source is equal
to the velocity of the wave well if
these two quantities are equal up here
you have something subtract the same
thing from it this numerator right here
becomes zero so it'll turn this whole
thing into being zero so the period or
the observed period will be zero which
means you don't have to wait any time at
all between successive crests that the
that D that the entire waveform just
gets infinitely bunched together so it's
just you know just it's just kind of
like one impulse and if we look at the
frequency we can either look directly at
the formula and you'll see well you have
something divided by zero right here so
you could say this is one over zero or
you could just say that the frequency is
one over the period and you get this
thing that's undefined undefined but if
you want to think about what does a
frequency approach as the velocity of
the source approaches the velocity of
the wave if this thing is only a little
bit less than that thing this is going
to be a very very very small very very
small positive number so when you divide
these quantities by that very very very
small positive number you're going to
approach infinity so the frequency is
going it's undefined at the speed at
the velocity of the wave but it's going
to approach infinity approach infinity
it will approach infinity as the source
approaches the sound as far as the
source approaches the velocity of the
wave not necessarily a sound wave I keep
using sound wave just because that's how
I tend to visualize things we'll talk in
future videos specifically about sound
waves and we'll touch on it a little bit
in this video so what is this telling us
does this make any sense and if you
think about it at least into me you know
it starts to make it starts to make
sense just what you saw in the last
couple of videos in the last couple of
videos when something was moving slower
than the speed of sound you had okay I
am here now and then maybe and I'm about
to eat to release the next crest if I go
one period ago maybe I was right there
and the crest that I had released at
that time period maybe has traveled this
far just like that if you go a period
before that I would have been over there
and the crest that I released then would
have traveled that far we saw this in
the last two videos and if you go the
period before that I would have been
there and the crest that I would have
released would have been that far and
this was the whole reason why the
Doppler effect happens because the
observer sitting right here let me do
this in a separate color the observer
sitting right here is going to
experience these crests more frequently
than an observer sitting out here
because the wavelength gets compressed
because every time this guy releases a
new crest or a new cycle he is moved
forward he has moved forward in the
direction of this motion right here so
let's think about what happens when he
is exactly moving at the speed of the
wave so let's say that the source is
here now
this is right where he is and he's right
about to release a new crest so where
was he at one period ago so let's say he
was here one period ago and where is the
crest that so one period ago he if he
was if he's right going to release a
crest or cycle right now one period ago
he would he released another cycle and
where has that cycle gone well we're
assuming that the wave is
traveling at the same velocity as this
guy but it's going radially outward so
whatever he released then it will have
traveled at the same velocity as himself
so it will got it will have gotten this
far right he released it one period ago
and that's where he was one period ago
over the course of the next period he
traveled there and so did the wave the
wave also traveled there now where was
this character two periods ago two
period when I talk about the period I'm
talking about the actual period of the
wave every period or kind of how long
does it take between similar points in
the cycle and I like to think of them as
the crest in the cycle so two periods
ago he was here and he released a you
could imagine a pulse or crest and where
will that be now well that will have
traveled as far as he did he traveled
that far and so will the pulse that he
released it will have traveled fact you
have to make it a little bit more
symmetric it will have traveled that far
so it will have traveled that far it
will have travelled that far then if you
go three periods ago I think you get the
idea if you go three periods ago he was
here and he released he released a pulse
then or a crest or or or a cycle of the
wave and where will that be now well it
will have traveled as fast as he's
gotten so it will have gotten this far
so it will have gotten that far of
course it's traveling that velocity in
every direction radially outward now
think about the situation for the
observer think in particular think about
the observer who's sitting right here
let's say he's just out of the way so
that this thing doesn't run into him and
kill him and whatever else but he's just
out of the way just enough to experience
the sound but not be directly collide
with this object that's emitting the
what I shouldn't say sound emitting the
wave I want to be general right here
we're not assuming that this is a sound
wave what's he going to experience well
he's not going to well if we assume this
is a sound wave he's not going to hear
anything until the thing passes right
there and right when the thing passes it
has all of the sound that it generated
coming with it at exactly that moment in
time instead of hearing things instead
of hearing things periodically all of
the wave fronts
smack this guy all at once and
perceptually instead of hearing a pitch
because you're hearing something
periodic because you're just going to
hear a big thump because all of that
sound energy is getting to you at the
same time you're just going to hear a
thump because it's no longer really a
frequency all of the energy is coming to
you at the same time and we're talking
about sound specifically and especially
when you are transonic which means
you're around the speed of sound or
parts of you are are above or below the
speed of sound and you move into
supersonic speeds that's what people
relate to the sonic boom and we're going
to talk a little bit more about that in
the next video and Mach numbers all of
that because I just find all of that
fascinating but I think this is
intuitive because when you look at this
all of the way everything is just
reaching you at exactly the same time
and you know that this was the case it
sound waves but it would be true of any
type of waves